Hey everyone, this is Ryan here and welcome back to our prosthodontic series.
And now we're going to start to talk about partial dentures.
And the things we talked about with complete dentures like essentialist anatomy, vertical
dimension of occlusion, support, stability, retention, all those things still matter here.
But now we'll talk about things exclusive to partial dentures.
And the big difference with partials is that the patient still has some of their teeth.
And depending on what teeth they have, they're given a specific Kennedy classification.
And that's what we'll focus on in this video.
So again, different people are missing different teeth, and the Kennedy classification system
seeks to group certain patterns of essentialism into these different classes.
So Kennedy Class 1 is a bilateral distal extension.
And a distal extension means that all the teeth distal to a tooth are missing.
So bilateral, meaning that there's a distal extension on both the patient's right side
and their left side.
So this would be an example of Kennedy Class 1, where the patient is missing all of their
teeth distal to both first premolars in this case.
Kennedy Class 2 is a unilateral distal extension.
So only for this patient, they have a distal extension on their right side.
So how I like to remember this is Class 1 has two distal extensions, whereas Class 2 has
only one distal extension.
Class 3 is a unilateral bounded-adentialist space.
And a bounded-adentialist space is a space of missing teeth that has teeth on either side
of it.
In other words, a bounded-adentialist space, an-adentialist space that's bounded on both
sides.
And lastly, we have Class 4, which is a bilateral bounded-adentialist space.
And bilateral, in this case, doesn't mean it happens on both sides of the mouth.
It means that the-adentialist space crosses the midline, like in this picture.
So those are our four classes, but there are some additional rules we need to keep in mind
to help us with classification.
And these are called Applegate's Rules.
And the first one kind of goes without saying, and it's that the classification should be
assigned after any extractions.
So in other words, you wouldn't classify a patient until after they got all the necessary
extractions of teeth that they needed.
Teeth that have a hopeless periodontal prognosis, or teeth with a non-restorable condition, these
are not teeth you're going to include in their Kennedy classification, because in the treatment
plan, they're going to be removed eventually.
Rule number two is that missing third molars are not considered.
So if the patient is missing their upper third molars on both sides, we wouldn't call this
Kennedy Class 1, because those would not be considered distal extensions.
And rule number three, abutment third molars are considered.
So third molars, like this one, that are present and would need to be used as an abutment tooth
to help support the partial denture, well this one is considered as a tooth bounding
this essentialist space.
So in other words, let's remember that missing third molars do not count against the patient,
whereas present third molars do count as an abutment tooth towards the classification.
Alright and now rule number four is that missing second molars are not considered.
And more accurately, this rule says if a second molar is missing, and is not planned to be
replaced by the partial denture, in other words that tooth is not going to be included
as a denture tooth in the partial design, then it's not considered as part of a distal
extension, same as for the third molars.
So say the third molars and the second molars are missing, and the partial will be designed
only as far back as the first molars.
Then we don't care about the second molars, and we're not calling a missing second molar
a distal extension.
So at this point you may be thinking, well Ryan, what if there's a distal extension and
abounded a denture tooth space?
Well this next rule is probably the most important one of all of them.
And that's the most posterior edentulous area determines the classification.
Now the most posterior edentulous area determines the classification, while other edentulous
areas are referred to as modifications.
So in this example, we have two distal extensions and one bounded edentulous space.
Now according to rule number five, the distal extensions are tied for being the most posterior.
And distal extensions by definition are always going to be the most posterior edentulous
area because they're no teeth distal to them.
Now this is convenient because we have a classification for bilateral distal extension, and that's
Kennedy class one.
Well, but what do we do with this other edentulous area?
Well it's a modification, and how do we classify modifications?
Well it's nice and simple, thankfully, it's just by how many there are.
So if this is Kennedy class one, and there's only one modification, we're going to call
it Kennedy class one, modification one.
And that's it.
And rule number seven is basically what we just said, that the extent of modification
doesn't matter, doesn't matter how big it is, how many teeth are involved, only the amount
of additional spaces in addition to what's needed to define the classification.
And we'll go over a lot more practice later in this video so you can really get to practice
these concepts.
And we have one more rule left, rule number eight, is that class four cannot have any modifications
by definition.
And this is actually completely logical and reinforces all the previous rules.
A class four bilateral bounded edentulous space will always be by definition more anterior
than any other possible edentulous space that could determine a classification.
There can't be an edentulous space that's more anterior than something that crosses the
midline.
So class one, class two and class three will always triumph over a class four, so you can
never have a class four with any modifications.
Alright so we covered all four classes and all eight rules, now it's time for some practice.
So go ahead and pause the video and then we'll go over the Kennedy classification for this
edentulous arch together.
Alright so this is a picture of a partially edentulous upper arch.
And the first thing we're going to consider is rule number three, which is that the abutment
third molars are considered as part of the classification.
And just as a side note, you don't have to remember what number rule corresponds to what
rule, just so you can get an idea of what they all mean when working together.
So the abutment third molars are going to be considered, which makes these two spaces
bounded edentulous spaces.
Now they're also both equally posterior, they both involve a missing second molar as
their most posterior spot, and note here that the missing second molars do count because
we have these third molar abutments.
So by rule number five, this would be considered a Kennedy class three, but according to rules
number six and seven, if we count one of these as towards the class three, we need to count
the other one as an additional extra space, which would make it a modification.
So this one would be Kennedy class three, modification one.
Alright let's try another one.
Go ahead and pause the video, and then we'll talk about this together.
Alright so this one is a partially edentulous lower arch, and otherwise it's pretty similar
to the last one.
You notice there are three bounded edentulous spaces this time, and two of them are tying
for being most posterior, in this case involving a missing first molar as being the most posterior
teeth.
So since we have three bounded edentulous spaces, two of them tying for most posterior, we can
count one of them being towards the Kennedy class three, and that leaves two additional
ones left over, so that would make this a Kennedy class three, modification two.
Alright so go ahead and pause the video, and then we'll go over this one together.
Alright so this is a partially edentulous upper arch, and this one has a distal extension,
which again will automatically win the battle of being most posterior by definition of distal
extension.
So this, in addition to this one, this would make it a Kennedy class two, remember class
one has two distal extensions, class two has one, and now we're left with a couple bounded
edentulous spaces.
There's one here, and these might be a little bit hard to see, but there's actually a bounded
edentulous space here, and here as well.
And yes, even just one tooth missing makes it a bounded edentulous space.
So in this instance, we have the distal extension going towards the classification, and three
modifications left over.
So this is going to be Kennedy class two, modification three.
And we have one more practice problem, go ahead and pause the video, and then we'll talk
about this.
Alright so this one is again a partially edentulous upper arch, and we have a bilateral distal
extension, which will automatically classify this as class one.
Now you'll notice we have a bilateral bounded edentulous space, which if it occurred by
itself, without this class one back here, this would be class four, but since we already
have our class one, this whole thing becomes just one modification.
So this may look like it's very complicated, but it actually turns out to be just a Kennedy
class one, modification one.
Alright, so that's it for this video, I hope it was helpful in learning how to apply the
Kennedy classification in Applegate's rules to determining different patterns of edentulousism.
Thanks so much for watching everyone, and we'll see you all in the next video.